the slowdown in the Chinese economy
doesn't just hurt China some us
companies do a lot of business there and
have counted on the emerging economy to
help Drive their profits during the
second quarter S&P 500 companies
mentioned China 182 times that was the
fewest number of times since the fourth
quarter of 2021 but as the third quarter
earning season starts to heat up in the
US there are three big reasons you're
likely to hear a lot more about China
from American companies first companies
that generate big chunks of their
revenue from China are driving much of
the stock market's gains this year the
S&P 500 Index is weighted based on how
large each company in the index is and
in recent years tech companies have come
to dominate companies like Tesla apple
and Nvidia have been responsible for
much of the rise in the S&P this year
and they all do a lot of business in
China while only 75% of revenue for
companies in the S&P 500 comes from
China about 16% of revenue for companies
in the information technology sector is
China based for Semiconductor companies
like Nvidia 27% of Revenue originates
there and when the Chinese economy slows
down like it has this year that usually
means Chinese businesses and consumers
buy less that includes us
products second we've seen Rising
tensions between the US and China with
both countries recently unveiling new
restrictions on trade sources told my
colleague Yoko Kubota in September that
officials at central government agencies
in China have been told not to bring
Apple's iPhone to the office and Beijing
recently instituted a ban on Chinese
firms buying products from Idaho based
chipmaker Micron the company said
earlier this year that the ban could
have a quote double digit percentage
impact on its total sales China has also
ramped up bans on foreigners leaving the
country targeting bankers and Executives
the US has also made things more
difficult for American companies doing
business in China Banning the sale of
chips and other Tech equipment to
Chinese companies nid is Chief Financial
Officer recently said that further
restrictions on sales to China would
result in a quote permanent loss for the
US industry to compete and lead in one
of the world's largest markets third the
Chinese economy slowdown is having a
wide range of negative effects China's
unemployment rate is picking up
especially for young people who are some
of the biggest consumers of americanmade
products the unemployment rate for
people aged 16 to 24 has doubled over
the past 4 years and Rose to 21% June
the highest level ever China's
government suspended the survey after
June's record reading and has cut off
data releases for corporate registration
information patents and more the
country's Yuan currency also fell to its
lowest level in 16 years against the
dollar last month that means products
sold in China will be more expensive for
local consumers or they'll have to be
marked down in dollar terms which means
less money comes back to us companies
companies may still be able to hit their
targets despite these headwinds from
China but get ready to hear a lot more
about them in the coming
weeks